this girl who was in such a small
minority she is a real disproportional
power they're the ones in charge of
what's gets but what gets published they
are the ones in charge of how the media
covers it they're the ones who write a
letter to get somebody banned from
campus most students don't want that
it's the crazy girl stealing the manga
hat the trig leader this one this next
clip this segment a few clips that we
actually have yes some protesters have
changed my mind
so every time another question of the
day two people out there what do you
think the campus climate is like do you
think that protesters are actually
starting this sort of die-off they're
becoming an endangered species that's
been my experience when we were at UT
and we have some more change my mind's
coming up you can see this here we were
there we had a productive day it was
mostly pretty civil in this girl tried
to yank someone's mug a hat off and you
can see her there talking with the UH
the police officer police actually are
getting dangerously close to assault she
ought ironically used the word trigger
than safety with the police officer not
even a hint and told everyone that she
didn't feel safe there you can see her
saying this here she doesn't feel safe
here she shot this place out at the same
time this is what scares her this kind
of a conversation with some we had this
all day all day there were only three
incidents of people who who got upset
she comes out doesn't feel safe
complains to the Student Activities
coordinator by the way you can also see
here's no she complained about a privacy
violation afterwards on YouTube which
doesn't even respect the law what when
you look at single party consent states
let alone at a public protest it's much
I show you this because I think it's
important to see all of these people
look at all the students with hundreds
of students half of them were left half
of them are right because a lot of these
students right away lined up wanting to
discuss these issues and disagree with
me or their fellow conservative students
but this girl who was in such a small
minority she is a real disproportional
power that's what bothers me they will
disproportionate power they are in
positions of academia 40% of colleges
have no conservative college professors
you can see the Dean of Students came up
here after ones panicking saying oh
people feel people feel scared you can't
do the
because you don't have a permit for two
people talking today it is not these
people don't make up the general student
body but they are the ones who get the
media coverage they are the ones in
charge of what's gets but what gets
published they are the ones in charge of
how the media covers it
they're the ones who write a letter to
get somebody banned from campus most
students don't want that it's the crazy
girl stealing the manga hat the trig
leaders this one but they are the ones
who are most motivated to write to
campus activities coordinators to get
people banned outside show this to you
to say it's a good thing it's a good
thing this is an exception not the rule
unfortunately it tends to be the status
quo for those in power in academia and
media and outside of that we really only
had one other person who looked to
create any problems that day and as you
can see the rest of the hundreds of
people there they weren't on board with
it if you liked this video subscribe or
click one of these videos playing in a
box you know what hit the notification
bail because subscriptions don't really
mean anything anymore especially if
you're not 18 or older at the very least
logged into YouTube as 18 or older
because sometimes people are 25 but they
don't know how to use the YouTube system
properly and then you never just tape
the notification pal or you hate
yourself